vingt mille personnes empruntent chaque
jour les transports car jeunes du
conseil départemental et dans les cas de
gare routière de ce réseau interurbain
saint pierre saint joseph saint benoît
et saint denis
c'est la valse des bus
les usagers peuvent s'informer à
l'accueil sur le tableau actualisé par
le chef de gare et depuis peu ils
peuvent aussi donner leur avis est à
l'écouté des gens première des choses et
en même temps ça va les retrouver pour
si tout ce qui met en place satisfait la
clientèle je dirais plutôt c'est des
gens des phares on a des gens qui
n'osent pas passer
pourquoi le renseignement
rien passer par une boîte à rêves
des pauses eux
mes remerciements les suggestions très
positif c'est oui en tant qu'autorités
organisatrices de transport interurbain
le conseil départemental veille au
développement de ce service
mais à l'heure du tout numérique avoir
le bon outil pour comprendre les besoins
est un vrai déficit et transports
représentent que sa croissance dans l'ue
dans les déplacements à la réunion et à
la réunion nous avons 400 mille
véhicules 320 mille voitures
individuelles 1500 bus donc si nous
pouvions faire que l'apport de ses 1500
bus soit un peu plus grande dans le mode
de déplacement ça nous ferait gagner en
qualité de vie surtout au niveau
environnemental
donc madame la présidente est sensible à
cette chose
nous avons fait des offres très
intéressant ces derniers temps j'ai avec
moi la corde réunis parce qu'ils étaient
un titre de transport intéropérables
valable que tous les réseaux de
transport
vous savez qu'on a mis en place la wifi
dans les réseau car jaune
donc voilà deux exemples concrets
d'amélioration des offres de services et
nous attendons de la population des
usagers qui nous donne aussi des idées
pour pouvoir améliorer leur leur voyage
en fait ce système d'information est le
fruit d'une volonté forte d'évolution du
service nous avons là par exemple un
mode un usager qui souhaiteraient que
sur la ligne hoarau 2 donc saint pierre
saint denis que les cadences soient plus
fréquentes soit plus rapprochés c'est à
dire il souhaite que normalement qu'on
mette un bus toutes les heures par
exemple au lieu des deux heures pour
éviter une trop longue attente dans les
gares routières
voilà c'est ce genre de de remonter ce
genre de
d'informations que nous attendons de
l'usagé pour pouvoir améliorer justement
le réseau car jaune
combinées les demandes et les conjuguer
avec les contraintes de la collectivité
permettra de mieux appréhender l'avenir
de ce réseau interurbain